Narrator: Imagine that you're
a red-blooded carnivore.
You love burgers, steak,
pork chops, bacon.
But one day, out of nowhere,
red meat starts to make
you physically sick to the stomach.
It sounds like science
fiction, but it's real,
and it's spreading.
It's spreading to people like Amy.
Amy: My name is Amy Pearl,
and I'm a producer for WNYC.
Narrator: She has what is called
a mammalian meat allergy.
Amy: I have a tendency to not
mention it at restaurants,
because I feel like if
you say to a server,
I'm allergic to meat,
they're gonna be like,
I'm spitting in your food.
Narrator: Any meat that came from a cow,
a pig, or a lamb, will make Amy sick.
Very, very sick.
Amy: Like I just had hives
on my hands and my feet,
and like all over my torso.
I was nauseous, and I
felt like I was fainting,
I felt like the world was ending,
I felt like I was gonna pass out
and I couldn't really breathe.
Narrator: Thousands of Americans
are suffering like Amy,
but until 2009, this sort
of allergy went undiagnosed.
Amy: I think I made an appointment
with my regular physician,
but he immediately was like,
there's no such thing as a meat allergy,
has to be something else.
Narrator: That changed with
the cancer drug, Cetuximab.
In a clinical trial, one
in four patients developed
severe allergic reactions to the drug.
Some even died.
Naturally, Cetuximab was investigated.
University of Virginia's
allergy department focused
on one specific part of the drug.
The key ingredient in Cetuximab
is a specific carbohydrate
that all non-primate mammals
carry in their cell walls
and tissues,
Galactose-alpha-1,3-galactose,
or, if you're pressed for time, alpha-gal.
Dogs have it, cats have
it, and the mice cells
involved in the production
of Cetuximab have alpha-gal.
The team discovered that
those who had reactions
were from only certain areas
of the US, the southeast.
The locations of the cases
aligned almost perfectly
with the range of a specific type of tick,
the lone star tick.
Dr. Scott Commins is an allergist,
and was working with the
University at the time.
Scott: Over 90 to 93% of our patients
that developed allergic
reactions to red meat
and test positive by blood test will have
a history of tick bites.
Amy: The thing I Googled
was "sudden meat allergy."
I found an article that
said there was some man
in Florida, had gone
into anaphylactic shock
from eating meat after a tick bite.
And I was like, "I had a tick bite!"
I mean, I often have a tick bite.
I'd just taken a tick off me.
Narrator: One of the leading researchers,
Dr. Thomas Platts-Mills,
went so far to use himself
in an unofficial experiment,
taking a hike through
a nest of larval ticks.
It earned him a nice
case of red meat allergy.
There's still a lot we
don't know about how
this meat allergy works, but
here is the leading theory.
Ticks don't have alpha-gal naturally,
but they could be carrying
it if they fed off a mammal,
like a deer or a dog.
If a tick then bites you, it trades some
of your delicious blood for its saliva,
which is a cocktail of nasty things.
An enzyme in that saliva
tells your body that there's
a variety of dangerous threats,
and your immune system bans
everything in that saliva
from entering the body,
including alpha-gal,
which is also in every burger,
steak, and bacon strip.
So the next time you eat one of those,
your body treats the
carbohydrate like an intruder,
and hits the panic button.
This is happening in the bodies
of an estimated 5,000 Americans.
What's worse is that the range
of the lone star tick is growing.
Scott: Their range is spreading into
the Ohio River Valley and
now up into Minnesota.
We also know places where this
alpha-gal red meat allergy
exists, but they don't have
lone star ticks at all.
And this would be southern
Sweden, for example,
there are parts of Europe, Australia,
and now even South Africa.
So clearly other tick
species can do this as well.
Narrator: University of
Virginia's researchers
have also linked the alpha-gal allergies
with a higher risk of heart disease.
Scott: This allergy seems
as though it will often
go away over time, but
the problem has been
that any additional tick bites seem
to cause the allergy to return.
And these are often patients
who like to be outside.
Amy: I know that my
numbers have gone down,
because I've been retested
a couple of times,
but they're still 10, 20
times what they should be.
Narrator: Dr. Commins
continues to work towards
an immediate cure to
mammalian meat allergy.
In the meantime, the
number of cases are rising.
Scott: So what we've
been trying to do is work
on a vaccine related to tick saliva,
in hopes that we can prevent
the allergic response
from continuing, or recurring,
with additional tick bites.
Narrator: If you've been
bitten by ticks recently,
be sure to get tested.
If you haven't, learn how
to explore the woods safely.
Scott: Well if you haven't been bitten,
then try to stick to the trails.
If you're going into a
heavy tick-infested area,
you may want to consider
pre-treating your skin
or clothing with DEET or
Permethrin, respectively.
Amy: People are so
freaked out about ticks,
it's not that bad.
They're much easier to see than you think.
Narrator: Learn how to do a tick check
after spending time in the wilderness.
And if you value a juicy
steak over a walk in nature,
then maybe stay out of the woods.